The one way property of hash function
is extremely useful for security.
Recall that the one way property means
that it is easy to compute a hash
from the message, but it is impossible
to find a message from the hash.
You can think of it this way.
You can make hashbrown from potatoes.
But you can't make potatoes
out of hashbrowns.
Let's look at this example of
using hash to verify password.
Hash is particularly useful for
password verification.
We all know that when we
authenticate ourself to a system,
we need to supply a password.
Now let's look under the hood.
What happens?
For example, when a user
supplies the password "candy,"
the system would take the input
"candy" and hash it, and
then compare the hash value with the
stored hash of a password on the system.
If they match,
then the access is allowed.
Otherwise, access is denied.
That is, the clear text password
candy is never stored on the system.
Only the hash of the password
is stored on the system.
And then whenever the user types in
a password to authenticate him or
herself to the system,
the input will be hashed.
And then the hash of the input
password will be compared
with the stored hash of the password.
You may ask, why not just store
the clear text password on the system?
Think about it, if you do that then
anyone who gains access to the system
can look at the clear text password and
then impersonate the user.
This can include attackers or
even other users on a system.
Therefore, we never store the plain
text of the passwords on system,
only the has values.
Of course,
if an attacker gains access to system,
he can steal the hash of the password.
Then what the attacker can do is guess
possible passwords one by one and
hash each guess password and
compare the hash value with
the stolen hash of the password.
If they match,
then the attacker knows that he had
correctly guessed the password.
Therefore, it is important for us to use
a password that's very hard to guess.
For example, we should not use
any word in the dictionary.